good morning everyone welcome to
legislative Administration um rep Tyne
can you lead us in the
pledge to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for it
One Nation God indivisible withy and
jusice for
all thank you very
much um first off want to thank our
substitutes today oh we've got new
entrance uh representative Malloy is uh
substituting
for uh P representative p and for the
first time ever representative Karen
evil is is here um substituting for our
ranking member Janet wall um thank you
both of you I
appreciate uh good
morning another school
bus did you get behind another school
bus chairman know
[Laughter]
everything
excellent well um we have one bill on
our uh agenda for today um Senate Bill
84 um don't be confused by the fact that
we only have one bill that so it'll be a
a uh uncomplicated Affair but uh it's a
Amendment on top of amendments on top of
amendments so um we've got we've got to
maintain some some intellectual uh
attention going here for a little while
um first off uh we
have to um I think right now I would uh
recognize uh representative
Shen uh for a motion of ought to pass
correct what's
that
uh we are actually in
hearings so what but what we have to
do I told you it was getting complicated
um what we're actually doing is
executing um s
sp84 but adding amendments and during
and the amendments are getting a public
hearing as we go
okay right that's confusing it is yeah
um clear because we have a separate
section you'll need your microphone when
you need to speak but um yeah it is it
is a confusing thing um we are holding
public hearings on amendments to Senate
Bill 84 but we're doing it in terms of
um an exact session on 84 because this
is the last well this is our last bill
and we need to perform perform our
duties to uh execute and remove or issue
a final
report so with that um first little
glitch um I would ask
uh repan for a motion on Senate Bill
84 I move a to pass
rean oh I'm being
waved
in ex
session the hearings first you didn't
notice
ex um but if we're going
to add amendments as we excuse me for a
minute
got
it you all knew this but apparently I
did not so um as it was put into the
calendar um the exec session will be
handled after the public hearings on
each one of the Amendments so the
Amendments will be heard individually so
at 10:00 we have
scheduled maybe I do better with glasses
um we have scheduled the public hearing
on um Amendment uh
um and for that I don't
see the prime
sponsor um but I can
fill
in I guess or would you like to talk to
it why don't you take the why don't you
take this the witness
table Prime sponsor
um shirtliff was supposed to
attend um and talk about uh the
commission that um he is the chair
of but for that I'll ask
repen to introduce the amendment thank
you yeah so I would like to introduce
Amendment
2023-24 um the prime sponsor again is
representative schliff and um what it's
doing is removing
um the John G winet Memorial commission
where we're removing it uh repealing it
from the list of commissions and um that
statue will now be taken care of
maintained by The Joint legislative
historical
committee thank you um would would you
entertain a question or two if there are
any
absolutely rep evil thank you um I'm on
the commission on commissions with the
chair represent ative Dolan there and I
know you're on it too is it not true
that um we had a discussion about what
to do with this particular commission
since the um the commission really was
created to establish the monument um and
so its time had kind of passed so either
it had to be amended um or the other
alternative that was suggested is that
it be transferred to the histor ioral
commission um and then I have a followup
is that not true that is true
establishing the record here okay and
then is it also not true that there was
a general consensus on the commission on
commissions to support this kind of
action to transfer it if uh um
representative shirtliff felt that that
was appropriate that's true okay thank
you and I would follow up that uh
rep shirt lift's um acquiescence with
that this movement is indicated by the
fact that he Prime sponsored the
amendment that came that is true thank
you further
questions seeing none thank
you if you can grab a pink
card
um as far as I can tell um we're good to
go um I had allotted 15 minutes um
having
heard rip sherff speak in the past we've
got uh especially on this topic um that
he is very near and dear to his heart um
we have 5 minutes before our next
scheduled public hearing and that would
be on Amendment 2023
H so sit
tight
okay here we are at 10:15 um we can move
move on to Amendment 2023
2372 H and I'd recognize our very fine
Deputy Chief of
Staff Deborah
Charles um this is a uh this is while
she's preparing and pushing oh it's
already pushed for the microphone um we
just had a couple of quick questions
about um this annual index on commission
and why it would be appropriate for that
to be removed from RSA 1449 at this time
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
honorable committee members happy to be
here again Deborah Childs Deputy Chief
of Staff for the
house because when this was written we
didn't have the functionality to pull
the information from the system but the
staff over the past year has been making
improvements on the statutory uh
commission process and a couple of
months ago we worked with it and created
an export function so if you're familiar
with the website where you can see the
statutory commissions there's now a
button there that says export and you
can export all of the data so I think
this is unnecessary and duplicative it's
also concerning because it says uh pull
the relevant information annually for
the speaker Senate President and and
other offices but it would actually be
that office which would know what the
relevant data is for each of those
offices so for example I work for the
speaker he needs certain information so
I would present that information to him
so this that could also be confusion
confusing but again it's I I believe
it's unnecessary and duplicative to have
them do something that we can do at any
point in
time thank you um you have a minute for
a question or two yes um first off I'm
going to start it it would seem to me
that um and and what we're dealing with
just so the committee is aware there we
have handed out to us
um it says at the top Title One the
state and its government and it's RSA a
copy of RSA
1449 what we're cons what this amendment
is concerned with is um e at the
bottom um the question I had or the
point that I wanted to make sure was on
the record was the fact that this was
going to be done once a year on January
15th but now through this um
availability it could be drawn at any
point in time any any point in time by
anyone exactly Mr chairman you could
push the export functionality and have
the report if you wanted to um but I
wanted to is the key if you wanted to
but as I work for the speaker I will
pull it for the speaker when the speaker
wants it with the information he needs
and as would the person who works for
the Senate President great are there any
other questions representative Eagle
thank you so one of the and and I think
you sort of answered the the issue but
one of the big problems that we found
when we were originally working with the
commission on commissions is that this
data it took like many many weeks to
pull all the data to assess whether the
commissions were really uh whether they
should be repealed whether they should
meet and all that sort of thing and so
one of the reasons that we put this in
the statute is just to make sure that
somebody was watching the you know the
hen house to make sure that all this
data was constantly being updated so um
one of the things on the chart that was
really useful that was sort of being
going to be reflected in the statute was
how frequently the Committees were
meeting and whether they were still
worthwh so what you're saying is that
you've updated all the it so all the
data that would have been in this report
is now going to be in the system like if
they're meeting is it a and and then a
lot of times you know a report is
basically reflecting what's inputed so
all the inputs are going to be there and
I just want to make sure that we're
tracking this year after year I know you
have similar concerns thank you for the
question representative unfortunately
the data in the system requires a lot of
cleanup so that's our next project to
tackle this export functionality has
helped us significantly with that um as
representative eel mentioned we have
separate spreadsheets so me working for
the speaker I had my own spreadsheet of
statutory commissions house committee
Services had one the senate had one and
I'm sure many other people who work for
a oting authorities have their own
spreadsheet so our goal is to
consolidate that get all on the same
page and just use the export
functionality from the tool so having
said that we don't have all of the
information that was in the spreadsheets
in the tool currently so we're tackling
that now two big efforts one we're
cleaning up the data and then two we're
making sure we have all of the fields
that we need and I promise you as long
as I'm here I'm not going to give up on
this project because it's a lot of
manual work that we could fix with an IT
solution
so we are all of us we staff have been
working on this for a year year and a
half now meeting regularly and and
trying to prioritize some of the
improvements uh to to help automate
processes so I cannot tell you today
that we have all of the data accurate
and all of the fields in the spreadsheet
that we need but we are working on it
and we do have a plan to get that done
so one of my concerns if if we left this
on here and if house committee Services
had to pull that information together
for January 15th it would be a
significant effort because one of our
challenges is getting that information
from the 300 or so commissions that we
have as you know but that's something
that we're working on how can we best
maintain this information first of all
clean up the data and get it accurate
and complete and then maintain it going
forward so I can tell you that we're
working on that plan and we're all very
passionate about it I think legislators
and staff equally uh because it is so
timec consuming um
but for that to be a reason to keep the
legislation really concerns me because
it would take a lot of time and a lot of
work and polling house committee
services and and Senate committee
Services away from other work that they
need to
do yeah I'll just do a quick B okay well
that that sounds great I mean I think I
the the other concern that we had when
we originally put this into statute is
just you know consistency from speaker's
office to speaker's office and just we
just really wanted to make sure that
there was a plan in place that these
things were constantly updated so if at
any points like legislative
Administration or if they wanted to look
at a set of commissions they'd have the
information there to decide so we just
didn't get into the hole that we were in
before so it sounds like there's a good
plan and it will come to the rescue I
hope so and if I may uh the way to get
it more consistent is to get everything
in the tool so instead of Deborah
child's updating her spreadsheet I'm
updating the system and so whenever
anybody chooses to run an export we're
looking at the live data we're looking
at the same thing I mean things as
simple as if I put in the name
representative kener and somebody else
puts in representative Kenneth Wier it
it's all going to be consistent going
forward whether it's a it's a name an
email an address requirements uh
statutory requirements it's it's going
to be
consistent I don't know why we had to
blame representative wer but
that's um any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your help thank you so
much we have no other pink cards um is
you can do that afterwards if you'd like
sure you'd like to speak on uh Amendment
2372 um chair would recognize
representative
Aly Susan elme
on uh W and means uh committee on
on uh Condominiums which I'll be talking
to you later but on I also on I started
that one and I started the dedicated
funds committee which does an incredible
amount of work every year now and um
both of them suffered from a number of
years that the Staffing was reduced up
here in the fourth floor and on that
they couldn't keep up up with all of the
filing we have years that are went
missing from the condo
association uh the condo committee and
and I know the clerk brought them up but
they we can't we haven't been able to
find them in it's been four years we've
been looking so
um and and the other thing is that on if
someone from that committee does not
look at the
um at the file the back file and talk to
them about what belongs there and what
doesn't on I pulled the condo committee
one and there was some stuff for
municipal and County and there was some
stuff for something else that was
totally irrelevant um that had been just
shoveled in there when they made the
changes over so they are they still have
a fair amount of cleanup to do on
these uh thank you um do you have time
for a question or two my question was
your your pink card and I know it was
rushed uh doesn't say you support or
oppose is is this idea of having this
automated and be able to pull up at any
time beneficial to you or yes yes I
think the automated is
terrific uh I was able to find find
finally with some help from the fourth
floor on the copy of a report that um on
the ways and meain side that we hadn't
seen for quite a few years great thank
you very much are there any other
questions for representative Aly seeing
none thank you very
much I have now no other pink cards
um with that I think we've passed our
time for uh this amendment if there's
nothing else to bring up um I'll move on
to um Amendment
2400h this is dealing with
uh a study committee um of the
environmental Ser Department of
Environmental
Services appeals process and um the
chair will recognize Vice chair Sheen
for introduction yes so this amendment
is is just a simple fix and and it's
just changing the date putting the date
out another year from November 1st 2023
to November 1st
2024 as um this committee hasn't um
meant to even um file a report in the
original report was due November 1st
2023 so they just need another year
thank you um my understanding was um the
members of the committee were notified
of the appointment just at the end of
October um so they had uh virtually days
um to to organize and meet so they at
their request they had asked if uh if
they could push this off for one year so
the only thing that's changing is to my
understanding on that Amendment
is the effective or the the reporting
date uh to November of 2024 that's
correct thank you any further questions
um it's not really a question but I I
was just going to say that I was in a I
was um I was an appointee to this
particular uh study committee and it was
something that was in
hb2 and I think it was just sort of Lost
in the shuffle and um it's true that um
we weren't appointed until the week
before the report was due um and it's a
worthwhile study committee and i would
support this amendment so thank you
thank
you seeing no other comments uh thank
you very much for
introducing uh Amendment
2400h and now we have one minute before
we we move
into um Senate Bill 84 Amendment
23998 so we'll reset for just a
minute
okay time being 10:30
um I would Rec the chair would recognize
Vice chair shien and her Amendment um to
Senate Bill
84 which is number 2023
23998 good morning again um okay so this
amendment um is the product of uh the
work that's been done in the special
committee on commissions that um the
speaker um appointed us to and created
um really it's to weed out um committees
and commissions um that have outlived
their work and purposes and um
alleviating um some of the work the
speaker has to do in appointing a
members to over you know 300 committees
and
commissions so um legislative services
at the beginning um when our committee
started meeting um handed us
um 10 committees or commissions that
they feel that need to be looked at in
order to determine if they should be
repealed or not so um these 10
committees were um divied out amend
amongst our members and uh we contact
contacted the chairman of these um
commissions and committees asking their
opinion if um they should be
repealed so out of the 10 uh we found
that
six um were ready to be repealed
and this is what this amendment does it
repeals those
six thank you um questions
seeing none um thank you very much for
help I would like to point out if you
look at the actual Amendment
um of
2399 um the the Committees that actually
are being repealed begin on line
24 and run through
32 um we have only one ping card and
that relates
to um Roman V beginning on line
31 um and that's from representative Aly
chair would call Representative
Aly welcome back to legislative
Administration
thank you Mr
chairman U represent Susan elme um city
of
Lebanon on board 17 I think you made me
um and
on on from ways and means but also um
the person who started the condominium
committee back around
2012 I think it was
and
um uh has been on it almost always since
uh no we it was in 10 that we we sat
down we've always been half Democrats
and half Republicans they're only four
of us uh and um in 2010 we sat down we
made a list of 12 things we thought we
needed to do when 11 started but then 11
was a little
chaotic and and everybody got taken off
the committee and some other people got
put on and on WE restarted in
13 and uh we have been working ever
since but we are facing some major
um problems on with the work we did re
uh add a great deal about governance of
cond s to the condominium law which had
been set up in
1977 uh in order to
restrain uh developers who were um
selling on to people properties that
didn't exist yet who were selling things
that hadn't been built correctly um on
on a bunch of other problems that I have
no idea what they were except there were
a lot of problems in the Market at that
point and so they set up something that
would protect the
uh on the people who were buying into
the
condos what they didn't do except very
uh
sarily was to tell the people in the
condos okay now you're the developer is
left you are running your own complex
you are responsible ible for
um all uh the maintenance of all the
Interiors you may be responsible for um
a septic system and you um are
responsible quite frequently for
roads um you are responsible um for
keeping people from killing each other
when they start fighting inside the
complex uh there you are a mini
government
and there is no Municipal Association to
help you learn to do that so the
boards on a lot of the bigger boards
hired property
managers and the property managers have
tended to take
over um not in all of them but in a fair
number of them we aren't sure how many
and they have taken over what the boards
were doing they've um got people elected
that would do what they wanted and they
have ignored the new law that we put in
a number of times that uh so that there
were not elections or if there were
elections they were based entirely on
proxies that were sent out to people who
were second homeowners and didn't live
there all the time and didn't really
want to be bothered so they just signed
the proxy and send it back
board um a lot of the condos are good on
we have on the current condo board um
a on the chair has lived in a
condominium for a number of years then
he moved to a homeowner association
we're also supposed to be working with
homeowner associations we haven't gotten
there yet because the
condominium part on has been been
blocked frequently in the Senate by um
agents of the largest property managers
in the
state who want to keep things the way
they are but we also have people coming
to us and now because I'm the
only surviving member of the condominium
committee from last term uh Senator uh
representative Ned Gordon having
retired uh and on the senator having
retired and um I
think think the other representative
didn't run again but
um on and I
get on many
requests from or appeals for help from
people that are in Condominiums that
have been going bad on Condominiums
where on the drainage has not been taken
care of for
years uh and they are Condominiums where
they level special assessments to take
care of the drainage or the roads and
then they use it for something
else yeah um my question is
we all get um calls from constituents
and and problems this is dealing
specifically with a study committee
right um so I'm wondering if if all of
the items um that I'm hearing about uh
whether it's problems with how documents
are are drafted um and the conversations
between the owners is that not outside
the scope of this study committee that
is up for being removed the study
committee when I uh started it as a side
gek I thought that it was going to be to
help
boards
uh uh run their many
governments uh instead we have been
dealing with a lot of of unit owner
condo board uh property
manager problems on that what that means
is we need an enforcement mechanism for
this we've had but again that's not a
stud that is what we have been
doing I understand but that seems
outside if if additional legislation is
needed to create that enforcement that's
fine that's what we've been doing and it
and it should be would see under uh
Roman
4E recommend statutory changes or study
model laws for possible Improvement to
New Hampshire laws that seems that it
would be
outside uh once that's
done the laws need to change not not
continue to act as that yeah no but I
have been acting like
it on recently the only one doing that
because the study committee exists and
people have been learning that it is
there and they have no idea where to go
on what we need is the condo dispute
board to get uh put into law but after
we have finally achieved that we will
cease having all these requests for
changes to the
law that we are filtering for the Comm
committee representative hunt can talk
to you about that but on we have been
filtering them to them because people
tend to put in a bill for their specific
condo problem it does not work across
the board so we have been helping
to to
uh make sure that the bills that come in
are going to be used usable if they
become law they're going to be
applicable to most Condominiums and the
other ones can get Exempted from it
because it just won't work for them um
the other thing that we have to do and
haven't done yet we're supposed to be
doing homeowner associations homeowner
associations work somewhat differently I
run one uh and
um they they do work somewhat
differently and they can't uh be put
under exactly the same laws we need to
spend more time talking with the people
from the homeowner associations to get
straight what law needs to be on the
books for them what they have now is
only their legal contract that was given
to them with their
deed um for their piece of the
property and it it doesn't
um it frequently does not fit the
circumstances that they need to deal
with I am seeing a number of questions
do you mind yeah rep evil thank you
thank you very much thank you
representative All U Al me for coming um
I am on the committee on commissions
with uh Vanessa and the the real um
issue that we were wrangling with is
whether to repeal
commissions um that aren't really doing
work anymore that aren't meeting that
aren't you know that have felt and we
really didn't inquire about the
substantive nature of the of the
Committees we were basically deciding
whether thing you know we were looking
at things that hadn't met for 10 years
for instance and so um I would ask you
rather than the discussion of the
substantive matter that your commission
is dealing with could you talk a little
bit about it it looks to me like you've
you've been meeting you've issued a
report you're not really filling the
you're not you're not really uh the type
of committee that we were suggesting be
repealed so the question
is are you intending I mean it looks
like if your if your uh chair wrote this
report you are intending to you have
been meeting you expect to continue to
meet yes and that's really the issue
that we're dealing with here uh in my in
my view anyway and then just coming off
of of where we were in the committee on
commissions and and so the reason that
this recommendation is even in this um
amendment is because we thought you guys
really weren't doing the job anymore uh
coming from us so if you could speak to
the fact that that you've been meeting
and if you continue to meet that's
really the issue rather than the
substantive nature of the committee in
my view anyway yeah well last
term I think it was not the term before
we didn't um formally meet at all uh
representative Gordon and I would get
there the senator never showed up which
he hadn't showed up in past years but
we'd had all three of the rest of us
working um and the the
um and so there wasn't a
quorum on the this year for the first
time we have four people who really are
committed to this work uh including the
senator and we've we were going to meet
three times but now the first time was
that time when it was 95 out and they
closed down down the uh lob so we
weren't allowed to meet um we um
the the chair said that chair infantine
said that we would would uh try to meet
in this month which I don't think is
going to work and next month to continue
to talk about um the bill that I was
talking about that is the enforcement
mechanism um so that they could all make
suggestions if they think it needs to be
redone the last time it was redone was
when uh representative Gordon uh
polished it a bit but I think it
probably needs a few small
changes I have another question from
Brett
mcarter thank you Mr chair so we have
this the report that you provided um
before you spoke and it's dated November
1st of this year so I'm I'm curious as
to uh is this the only report that is
available for that committee since it's
exception we have uh two sets of minutes
for the two
meetings and um we did
not this has been fairly normal over the
years which is part of the problem that
we're all so busy on our own committees
when we're in session that we were
supposed to start
meeting in the summer but we no longer
meet in the summer we have vacations in
the whole summer and so we don't start
until
September and then we have September
October the second year is constrained
by the fact that we're all by October
we're campaigning hard
um it does make this kind of committee
uh a little difficult to get ready for
the next year frankly so I put in the
two bills that we had been planning on
doing before last year and and um the
chair is signed on to the proxy one and
he wants to discuss the other other one
with the whole committee before we we
um um before they support it follow
up thank you uh
so the the purpose of this Committee in
the very very beginning back in
2012 was to study existing statute to
see um where there might be gaps or what
have you with regards to condo and
Homeowner Association uh organiz
structures and yes it was the purpose at
that time to also
um study that information and then take
feedback from constituents or homeowners
associations to craft new legislation to
try to plug those gaps or was it a kind
of as things came in it would give you
an idea okay that makes sense maybe
there's other people that are dealing
with this maybe we should you know um
create legislation to solve that problem
was this in your opinion an ongoing a
committee that was just going to be
forever because there would always be
evolving issues to contend with with
regards to those that's why we're trying
to get the enforcement mechanism it's a
kind of of uh
mediation on and once that's in place
when somebody has a specific problem in
their kind of condominium which doesn't
really apply to the others they can go
to that board and they can get case law
put into the court system this was done
by the
uh the UN manufactured housing board for
many years and they worked themselves
out of a job but will be out of a job
once we've got basic homeowner law that
we haven't started to work on yet Plus
on plus an enforcement mechanism right
now they can't go to the Attorney
General's office they won't deal with it
on they can't go they the only thing
they can do is go to Superior Court it
takes a minimum of two years and about
$20,000 to get heard in that
Court one more question follow up thank
you uh so do you have legislation in for
this session coming up for an En
mechanism yes it's the same one that we
were going to pass in
2020 when Co shut us all down do you
mind if we speak offline after the
meeting I have a couple questions that
relate to my living situation right
now see this is this
is what we had we had three totally
different kinds of groups come in in the
last two meetings to talk about about
their problems and it I must say it was
a very big education for the chair and
John scitech both of whom knew something
about Condominiums but it never run into
a bad
one rep
she yes so um thank you for taking my
question so the final re this final
report um and the legislation that you
um put in this
year you're saying that that will take
care of your commission and no no so
okay
so is your
commission do you want to continue your
commission in order to take feedback
from constituents and problems that
they're having in their condo and
homeowners
associations we
we are getting
feedback whether we want it or not still
on the condominium issues and some from
homeowner associations we haven't
started the work on the homeowner
associations yet and the other thing
that
until they have no place else to go they
come to us on for from the condo
associations now because there is no
enforcement mechanism in this State
except going to the superior court and
getting on a docket two years from now
well well correct me yeah correct me if
I'm wrong then shouldn't this commission
be repealed and a new
one um started because you're not
following um the purpose of the original
the the purpose is to draft legislation
and get it passed to
study laws relating to to study in order
to draft legislation and get it
passed and the second part of the
purpose is the homeowner associations
that we've been putting
off and because until there's an
enforcement mechanism it's not going to
help much um we've
um we've been passing laws and
I a couple of times I've I've written
letters at the behalf of of a condo
member uh to their Association board
saying here is the
law and uh sometimes that's worked and
they start obeying
it sometimes it doesn't because there's
no enforcement
mechanism great um any further comments
questions yeah I think we're good yeah
the legislation is about the enforcement
mechanism and then about homeowner law
great thank you thank you I would like
to
ask um chairman Dolan to I have a
question or two if you don't
mind welcome to legislative
Administration thank you Mr chairman my
question is um the charge of your
committee
um was it purely dealing with um
committees and commissions that are no
longer needed and or no longer
operating um does it have a feature for
those that are operating
outside their
um their original establishment
purpose uh well thank you for the
question uh We've uh continued the work
that was led by representative Ebert uh
for several years uh a lot of ditch
digging
and uh uh going back through the
process this this committee is a a great
example of what the charge really was
and that is to
find uh and and root out those
committees and commissions of the 300
and some other that out there churning
that we could eliminate or combine or
consolidate
uh so that this particular problem is
emblematic of what's wrong with our
system that so many of us are tapped on
the shoulder to to fill a role on a
committee or a commission that there's
just no time if if if you have so many
places to be people don't show up
because they're conflicted with other
obligations and therefore committees
don't meet or they don't achieve a
quorum and uh and that's a that's a
that's a systemic problem uh no no
comment individually about this
particular commission and it's and it's
the good work that uh a lot of the
people that are serving on it want to do
but the the issue we we we looked
at and on this particular commission is
there is definitely some work that needs
to be done with condo associations and
homeowners associations and so forth but
once that work is identified
then our recommendation to the committee
is to uh Implement legislation probably
through Commerce to fix whatever problem
that they found not to continue year
after year to have a commission that
very rarely if ever meets uh to uh again
just it churns the cost of government
that we're we're all trying to keep our
eye on that uh that's out there that we
want to try to to scale back I don't
know if I'm answering your question but
but the the the issue here is once an
issue has been identified in this case
on this committee the add issue the
issue is we need uh Stronger laws to
implement then that should get
transferred over in this case probably
Commerce to to uh implement the
legislation or to bring forth
legislation to accomplish that not to
continue to study it at infinitum um and
that's that's really where the
committee's at is thank you for your
answer um is your
committee um capable of creating
legislation uh we C we could uh there
are as you know there are only certain
opportunities or Windows in which to
create that legislation the next window
for us really is going to be next
year uh when the when the window opens
for new legislation or there is a an
alternate path through the rules
committee to enable special legislation
to be created with the approval of the
rules committee as an exception to the
rule uh and so so that window is
available to us I would I would suspect
that this committee that that I chair
will continue to dig at uh committees
and commissions to look for
opportunities to consolidate or reduce
the number of committees and commissions
that were all obligated uh to sit on and
to serve uh uh going forward final
question for me
um would it
upset the charge of your committee um
for us to e extend the time period um or
terminating this committee um to give
that time to be able to create create
the legislation in Commerce or whoever
um you suggest in order
to um better better determine the
purpose uh of of what's actually
occurring within the guise of a study
committee it would not up upset us at
all uh and I would defer it to uh
representative Sheen uh on that but uh
we have representative wall from this
committee representative Sheen we have
the minority leader uh we have
representative
Abel excuse me that uh that sit on this
committee and I think we're we're all in
general favor of allowing committees
commissions to continue that are doing
good work and V and add value to to our
process so we would certainly support
any decision you want to make along
those lines great thank you very much I
have one or two other questions for U
rep uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um regarding the
um condo associations it's my
understanding that Commerce just I think
this term um created um a subcommittee
just for condos and and and that sort of
thing because it you know it's just
grown to to a level that they they can
have their own subcommittee and it seems
to me that would wouldn't that be the
place for the ongoing as as we get ideas
for legislation that that it should that
this committee this study committee
could be funneled into that subcommittee
uh thank you for the question and I
couldn't agree with you
more rep Carter thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my
question I'm a freshman I'm trying to
make sure I understand this Theory
correctly is a
study committee relative to the laws of
whatever condos or Finance pollution uh
is the purpose of that committee to
study the activity within our government
related to that issue or is that
committee also supposed to function with
a marketing marketed effort uh to field
constituent concerns and questions I'm
I'm just trying to make sure I
understand it's my understanding was
these committees are kind of an internal
group working together to
solve issues interde departmental or you
know conflicting legislation it's not
necessarily something where you have an
Information Hotline that constituents
are reaching out to those study
committees am I incorrect uh no you're
absolutely correct the the purpose of
most uh study committees and commissions
is not to serve as a um as a complaint
uh desk for for the uh for constituents
that's that's something to be this
should these study committees and
commissions should be serving uh those
of you sitting around the table as you
consider uh what action to take or not
take uh depending on that particular
committee or commission so uh when
constituents have complaints they
certainly need to be dealt with uh and
that's one of the issues if I may Mr
chairman uh
one of the issues that we have is
especially with freshmen uh is that uh
what do you do with a a study commission
or committee how do you how do you
invoke one and when is the right time to
do that so so this committee that that I
chair uh it's a it's a committee of 10
of relatively senior people with
experience and what what they look at is
what's the process of doing this and
that that's one of the things we we have
focused on in the past year what's the
process so when you go to uh
OS with a with a hot idea in your mind
fresh fresh probably from a meeting with
constituents at a in the back of a
school board meeting or or or a council
meeting or whatever you come all
energized ready to imp to uh to study
something and what happen is you go to
OSS and you tell them what you want to
get done and and going forward what
they're going to be giving you back is a
a set of
instructions to to suggest how you go
about doing that have you considered X Y
and Z have you considered 1 two 3 4 and
that will help pair down the 300 or so
more commissions one of the things if
you if as you get beyond your freshman
uh term you're going to hear uh feedback
that's from o from others
Representatives that says something like
this well I know that's important to a
couple of constituents in my particular
community
so uh I don't see a lot of interest
elsewhere in the legislature so what
we'll do is we'll study it that's kind
of the fallback well let's study it so
and and and that might be the right
thing to do but but when when that's our
fallback what happens is our system gets
clogged with all these study committees
and commissions that we have very little
time to go off and do what we're
supposed to be doing because we're
sitting on so many of these commissions
and by the way many times we drag in
members of state government to sit on
these committees and commissions as well
that should be doing their work uh other
than that uh and at the hourly rate we
pay them it's a lot more expensive than
is for the $100 a year that you get paid
but they they're not at $100 a year
they're getting paid their due salary
and they to come and sit in a commission
that uh might spend 15 or 20 minutes uh
and then dismiss because a quum wasn't
achieved it's a very sad thing and it's
it's a sad commentary on the management
of of the cost of state government so we
want to be able to satisfy constituents
concerns we want to be able to satisfy
issues in this particular case about
condo associations and homeowners
associations we want to do it
efficiently and if action needs to be
taken in this case by uh a standing
committee like a Commerce Committee then
let's do it let's not just keep studying
it for years like this
particular uh operation has been
working I hope that answered I think it
did did um are there any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for taking the
time okay folks um we've heard our
public hearing on four amendments
um we can we are now past 11 o'clock we
can open the exec session on Senate Bill
um I would still
like to proceed as uh an ought to pass
and then have discussion about each of
the Amendments as we go and just leave
it free form wide open you can discuss
any of the Amendments that we have going
at the same time
um if there are further amendments that
are needed that would be fine um I have
two prepared um we can discuss those but
uh but at the moment
um I would suggest or ask um repen to um
for a motion on Senate Bill
84 I move ought to pass repen moves
ought to pass is there a second second
second by rep tyy
um there are four amendments um the bill
is open to Amendment uh um does anybody
want to have conversations about any of
the
four I thought you might yes well um I'm
in full support of the amendment
regarding the winant memorial I think uh
we we chatted about this a little bit
earlier and within the committee on
commission it made sense uh for a
memorial commission that had kind of
achieved its purpose to be transferred
over to the historical commission for um
oversight and maintenance so I'm
definitely in support of that one um the
I did have some questions about the
amendment um that removed the annual
indexing of commissions but it sounds
like everybody's on task and pulling in
the same direction so uh the what this
particular section was trying to be
trying to achieve is being achieved I
hope in a better way so I'll support
that Amendment um the um what was the
other one oh the amendment on the
environmental councils I'm on that it
does need to or I saw was on that I'm I
think the work needs to be done so I
support that um the only one that I have
some misgiving about is
2399 as it's structured you did uh ask
chair Dolan whether he would be amable
on behalf of our committee to extend the
life of the condo study committee by one
year I think based on the input from
representative Aly that would be a good
idea and if there was another amendment
that made that
accommodation I would support that
thank you R anyone
else you are the minable commission here
committee
um I um I too um would
support on the final Amendment uh the
2399 H um I
am persuaded that um while I
don't well I don't believe um the work
that the study committee is actually
doing um
follows uh what the original purpose of
the of the language is um in the in the
RSA I do think that it's valuable and I
do think that um they should be given
the
opportunity to make the
case as it says um recommend statutory
changes and study model laws uh for
possible Improvement I think that's what
they're doing um and I think they have
um perhaps uh it's not within this
commission this committee's duties to
determine whether those laws are are um
appropriate or not I think that has been
pointed out that it should be done
within Commerce um and I understand that
there is an LSR at least maybe a bill
number now for doing some of that um I
would have no problem
extending or amending uh 23 99h um on
that
particular
um committee list um of those six to
extend that for an additional year um I
think I think that would be appro
rate um rep M and I'm fine with all the
other three I mean they all just seem to
make sense to me uh it's it's more of a
cleanup than anything else cleanup on
aisle to um rep mcarter you have a
point would this uh Senate Bill 84 would
this be um an appropriate addition or
amendment to that bill to require when a
new committee or or um task force um
commission is established that it must
contain some sort of a Sunset date it's
got to have its work concluded by uh you
know whatever the the Germaine period of
time would be for the particular item is
that is this the bill that that kind of
language should should work it around
into is that a question to the
chair
is it possible
to you've seen right now we're building
an Omnibus build basically um so is it
possible to go on there sure it's
possible um I would suggest however that
um there are
already in statute are Provisions that
do exactly what you're saying um there's
actually an LSR I've seen that actually
is is talking to that as well so my my
opinion is it wouldn't be necessary
here I'm sorry oh sorry so you're saying
that there already is statute that uh
prescribes for
that yes and what is does that pertain
to every study committee um I can look
it up myself yes it does um it's in
actually if you look on the the sheet
here for 1449 yeah if you look
at uh B under Roman
2 okay I think that's what you're
talking about is that right
people the thing is
um this committee on commissions and
committees is working
through all of those and I'm not sure if
it's all 300 but but a lot of those were
created prior to this going into effect
I see so a lot of those I think will be
taken care of by that five-year Sunset
but right now they're working on those
that prior to that fiveyear window
occurring rep sers yeah thank you Mr
chair
so so it's I I think all of these should
uh ought to pass at this point here and
as far as giving another year that's
really that's being generous I think
honestly
um especially that one committee there
as far as Condominiums and
homeowners it's been in business for 14
years 14 years I mean how many more
years do you need to study something and
it seems like
almost every
banal since we're changing
Representatives all the time and and
even Senators it seems like we're we're
starting all over again so or for the
most part so I I think it should just go
as it is and uh that's my thought on
that thank you thank you anyone else
feel free to go around the room
here well let let's just start with a
straw pole on the first one does anyone
have any problems or any concerns on
241h all in favor of that say I I all
opposed so we're good
there um St pole on 23 372 H which is
dealing with
um the annual index of all of the
commissions that now is available online
and can be drawn up at any time does
anyone have any issues
there all in favor say I I
opposed then
H um this is the bill that because of um
whether it's a snafu with it being in
hb2 or just no one understood that it or
recognized it and it came out late and
everyone was appointed late and now they
want an additional year are there any
discussion points on
that all those in favor of
2400h
signify by saying I I
opposed now we get to 2399 H um all
those that um I'm going to go out on the
limit say all those that are
opposed um no all those that are in
favor
of allowing an addition year before
termination signify by saying I I Al
those
opposed it sounds to me like there's
more eyes than there were
nay
um I suppose there's a third option in
there um of completely pulling it from
that list of six and and it going on on
its merry way I don't feel that the
committee um well I'll I'll put it out
um does anyone want to just pull that
completely and and uh and let it
continue to go as it on its
own question U yes for chairman
Dolan uh your committee is still uh
functioning um it's still got time to go
so you'll still be looking
at uh reviewing various committees and
commissions that are still functioning
you would still be uh reviewing them so
if this one's totally pulled out right
now you'd take a look at it at your next
meeting next year or the year after and
see if it was a good time to get rid of
it at that
point yes thank you for the question um
yes
uh but uh know that this window of
opportunity is by uh piggybacking on
this
amendment the uh if a subsequent a
action were to be taken on this as as a
standalone it would need special
permission from the rules committee in
order to bring that forward which we can
get I think we can get depending on the
speaker uh and uh his staff but uh it's
it's just more difficult but it can be
done okay thank you thank you rep Sheen
yeah and I understand what you're saying
there rep attorney but if we're going to
do that we might as well just extend it
a year um and keep that change in the
amendment you know instead of throwing
it back to the special committee on
commissions where we have a lot more
things to look at as well we've looked
at this and you know we're making a a
graceful um compromise and letting it um
have another year
now
um my opinion so here we go um I have
[Music]
two amendments
coincidentally
um in my hot little hands here uh one of
them and and what I'll do is is call the
role on uh the official role on two on
these two what we have to do is
consolidate uh a bill can only have one
Amendment so what we're doing is
consolidating all of these into one
Amendment onto Senate Bill 884 replacing
all the language that exists on Senate
Bill 84 with one or the other of these
two amendments that I
have one of
them extends
for a period of one
year
um that one um Roman V that we're
talking about on
Condominiums the other one removes it
immediately um that's the only
difference between these two
amendments so what I will do is call the
role on those
two and um the one that
passes will be the one that gets
submitted
with Senate Bill
84 rep
cable um well can we we we could just do
the the one-year extension if that pass
and we don't do the second one right we
can yeah
okay we good with that any problems we V
so here we go um the
one that
changes actually why don't I hand this
out let me see which one I'm handing out
so I can tell you which one I'm handing
out
um this is the bill this is the
amendment yes all right what you're
getting is the
amendment that moves the effective date
of termination on that
single committee on
Condominiums study committee on
condominiums by one year so and it would
show up on page two at the very bottom
line
33 section five paragraph V of this act
will take effect January 1st
2025 there any discussion on that
Amendment everybody
open seeing
none I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll the new clerk to call the
room okay um we're voting on Amendment
2023 24
34h I should um let me just quickly
point out I want to make sure everyone
understands this is
inclusive of
241h 2372 H
2400h and
2399 H with that one
change that's what we're voting on okay
okay um clerk votes yes rep
sellers
yes rep
costable
yes rep mcarter yes rep
Tierney yes rep eel yes yes rep nutting
Wong yes rep
chott
yes rep
Monti yes R Malloy yes chairman Hill yes
110 I think that renders the Second
Amendment move at that point
um that would mean we have
amended Senate
Bill
um so we need we need an oop pass as
amended um but we need first a
motion to move Senate Bill 84 as amended
ought to pass rep she in yep I move
Senate Bill 84 as amended ought to pass
could you add the amendment number and
the amendment number is
2023-24
34h I want to double check
just so we don't have to come back
again yes um it's amended with 23 20 uh
34h
um any further discussion I'll second
the motion thank
you any further
discussion actually you're a substitute
I um rep marter will will
second not to point my finger at you I'm
sorry about that
okay
um good uh no further
discussion we're voting on ought to pass
Senate Bill 84 as amended with
2434 h
clerk votes yes representative sellers
yes representative costable
yes representative mcarter yes
representative Tierney yes
representative eel yes representative
nutting Wong yes representative
chott yes representative
Monti yes representative Malloy yes
chairman Hill yes big yes
um even though this is a Omnibus Bill at
this point I don't believe there's any
reason why we couldn't have it on
consent if without
objection uh we'll put it on
consent and I think that thank you for
following along the bouncing ball here
today and and the one error on my part I
appreciate the help of our substitutes
um that concludes our work for today um
and for this term no this year of the
term um again all of your work is
greatly appreciated and that's it uh
thanks very much I'm closing the exec
session on Senate Bill 84 as
amended tada
oh